YOUR HAIR IS DRY. YOU HAD THE
LOOK AN HOUR AGO
OF GUY WHO WAS RUNNING LATE.
GOT OUT OF THE SHOWER, GOT
DRESSED AND RAN OUT THE DOOR
BECAUSE YOU HAD KIND OF THAT
WET HAIR. LIKE, I DIDN'T HAVE
TIME TO REALLY DO ANYTHING
TODAY. AND I JUST WANT IF I GO
OKAY, ONE
KNOW I WAS SITTING HERE IN
THIS SEAT 20 MINUTES BEFORE
AIR TIME
TO, I WENT TO SLEEP AT 1:30 IN
THE MORNING BECAUSE THE CUBS
WERE PITCHING A NO-HITTER
A TEAM NO-HITTER, THAT'S
DEDICATION.
THREE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT 3 IS. I LOST
THREE BECAUSE I WAS UP TILL
NOW.
ALL RIGHT, THAT WORKS.
LET'S ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS
FROM THE
PFT MAILBAG
ON OUR FINAL EDITION
BEFORE
OUR INVOLUNTARY SUMMER BREAK
AT
J-TRAIN 33 BETWEEN YOU TWO WHO
WANTS AARON RODGERS TO BE THE
HAPPIEST AND HAVE HIS BEST
YEAR. THERE'S NO QUESTION.
IT'S YOU, THAT'S YOU'VE BEEN
EXPRESSING GENUINE
CONCERN FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND OVERALL PHYSICAL
PHYSICAL WELL-BEING.
BEING OF AARON RODGERS FOR
WEEKS. NOW,
HE IS A CRY FOR HELP.
HE FEELS MISTREATED
AND YOU CAN'T, YOU CAN'T
HAVE THAT, YOU KNOW, IN
TODAY'S WORLD
IF YOUR BOSS IS MISTREATING
YOU YOU GOT TO GET OUT. SO
AARON RODGERS, YOU GOT TO GET
OUT MAN. LIFE'S TOO SHORT,
LIFE'S TOO SHORT TO BE
MISERABLE
AT YOUR WORKPLACE AND YOUR
MISERABLE AT YOUR WORK PLACE
RIGHT NOW. SO, I
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT AARON
RODGERS
AND HIS WELL-BEING,
AND HIS HAPPINESS, AND HIS
MENTAL
STATE. SO,
REALLY JUST WANT TO SEE HIM
HAVE
LIVE LAUGH AND LOVE, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN? DANCE LIKE NO
ONE'S WATCHING, THAT KIND OF
OF STUFF.
ALL KIDDING ASIDE. I REALLY DO
THINK HE IS GOING TO PLAY THIS
YEAR.
WAIT, I WASN'T KIDDING. I WAS
NOT KIDDING. I WAS
KNOCKING. I KNOW, I KNOW, I
KNOW. I WAS NOT KIDDING. I
WON'T BE OUT
ALTHOUGH LISTEN. I
I DO THINK IT'S A BETTER STORY
AS I SAID EARLIER, FOR ALL OF
US, WHO COVER THE NFL,
IF HE IS THERE, THERE
THERE IS SO MUCH
POTENTIAL
AMMUNITION FOR DYSFUNCTION
IF HE'S THERE, IF HE DID, HE'S
NOT WHAT SORT OF TALK ABOUT,
YOU KNOW,
JORDAN LAW OF, AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE VERY
GOOD AND MAYBE THE
THERE'S OUR GREAT VALUE OF
PLUS 350 TO WIN THE DIVISION
BUT IF HE'S THERE
IT'S GOT THE POTENTIAL TO BE
VERY VERY COMPELLING.
WIRE TO WIRE
AND I THINK HE WILL BE THERE.
I WATCHED
MATT LAFLEUR'S FINAL OT A
PRESS CONFERENCE LAST
SATURDAY. I THINK IT WAS AND
THERE WAS SOMETHING HE SAID
THERE. THAT MADE ME THINK HE
KNOWS THAT ROGER IS GOING TO
BE THERE TALKING ABOUT CAMP
ARMS, BLAKE BORTLES, JAKE DOE
LA. JOLLA THE IDEA THAT, YOU
KNOW,
ONCE WE HAVE
AS WE GET
CLOSER TO
AMP MORE CLARITY
WILL PROBABLY BE MAKING SOME
MOVES. I THINK HE KNOWS THAT
AARON'S GOING TO BE THERE SO
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO NEED
THOSE. THOSE CAMP ARMS
THAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE TO
DISTRIBUTE ALL THE REPS DURING
INDIVIDUAL DRILLS.
I NEED THIS TO END NOW
FOR YOUR MENTAL STATE FOR
YOUR MENTAL HAPPINESS. MIKE
FLORIO. BECAUSE
JOYFUL. HEY BEN, ENTIRE
THURSDAY, GOING THROUGH THE
COVID RULES AND A SATURDAY
WATCHING. MATT LAFLEUR'S
PRESS CONFERENCE, SO IT WAS
TEN MINUTES. YOU 10 MINUTES,
WE NEED YOU
TO HAVE THE HAPPINESS THAT YOU
SEEK IN LIFE. SO AARON RODGERS
MAKE A DECISION. SO FLORIO CAN
STOP OBSESSING ABOUT
YOU.
IT WAS TEN MINUTES OF A
SATURDAY MORNING. IT WAS
BACKGROUND,
NOISE. IS THAT OTHERWISE WAS
WAS READING MORE DOCUMENTS
TO PUT SOME MORE
PINS TOGETHER, LIKE, CHARLIE
FROM
ALWAYS SUNNY IN PHILADELPHIA.
ALL RIGHT,
AT AND
NARENDRA,
I DON'T UNDERSTAND. THE FIRST
PART OF IT, WHAT IS A BIG CAT?
TOP 10 QUARTERBACK IN THE NFL?
I PREFER THE SECOND HALF WHICH
QUARTERBACK
DOES HE WANT TO BE BEARS
QUARTERBACK FROM THE
QUARTERBACKS WHO PLAYED AT
WISCONSIN UNIVERSITY ARE HAVE
THERE BEEN WELL?
GUESS IT WOULD BE RUSSELL.
WELL, IT'S RUSSELL WILSON.
THAT'S WHAT SORT OF BAD
PLAYING IT. WISCONSIN. IT WAS
EVER ANY GOOD
WHOA-OH. SCOTT TOLD, ZINE.
COME ON,
COME ON.
WOW. OKAY
SINCE ORGY
SO
REALLY WHERE THE GUY THAT'S A
COACH NOW,
NOW,
WHO IS ANOTHER GUY'S A COACH
THAT WILL
LEVEL. DARRELL BEVELL WAS
DARRELL BEVELL. YES,
YES, YES, YES, YES. IN THE
90S
TOP 10 QUARTERBACKS IN
GENERAL. SHOULD I JUST DO THE
LIST OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD TO
DO?
WE GOT THE LIST? GO AHEAD.
NO, I'M GONNA MAKE EVERYONE
REALLY MAD BECAUSE I'M GOING
TO FORGET SOMEONE AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE VERY VERY UPSET,
ALL RIGHT. OFF TOP, MY HEAD,
THIS IS BETTER THAN SIMS LIST.
JUST GUARANTEED
PATRICK MAHOMES ONE
AARON RODGERS.
TO TOM BRADY. THREE
JOSH HOLLAN FOR
JUSTIN FIELDS 5.
5, I'LL SHUT UP. JUST SHUT
DOWN. I SEE
JUST WHY NOT NOW GUYS
TUNE OUR TIME. NO I'M NOT.
OKAY NO I'M NOT KEEP GOING.
ANOTHER FUN-FILLED. BLAKE.
BORTLES
SIX KNOW LIKE BAKER, MAYFIELD,
SIX, BLAKE BORTLES
7.
JAY CUTLER, 9,
AND THEN
I WOKE UP.
RUSSELL WILSON 10.
ALL RIGHT. GET WELL DONE. WELL
DONE.
II KNEW THAT THAT BLAKE
BORTLES AND JARED GOFF ONCE I
HEARD JUSTIN FIELDS, I KNEW
THAT
THE LIST WAS GOING TO GO OFF
THE WHEELS, ALL RIGHT? THE
REAL DR. LIU WILL THE
STEELERS EVEN COME CLOSE TO
THEIR VEGAS, WIND. TOTAL OF
EIGHT AND A HALF WHEN IT
REALLY WASN'T SURPRISED
YESTERDAY TO HEAR THAT THEY
HAD RELEASED
DAVID TO CASTRO. THERE HAD
BEEN SOME RUMBLING BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
MANDATORY MINICAMP
THAT SOMETHING WAS UP, BUT
THAT'S JUST ANOTHER PIECE GONE
FROM THAT OFFENSIVE LINE.
HEY, WE'RE KEEPING BIG.
BEND, WE GOT A NOT J HARRIS.
WE GOT
JUJU SMITH SCHUSTER BACK. THEY
STILL NEED NOT OFFENSIVE LINE
OR NONE OF IT'S GOING TO WORK.
HOLD ON MIKE THOUGH
II SAW EVERYONE TALKING ABOUT
THIS YESTERDAY?
IT HAS TO BE ONE OR THE OTHER
HERE. THE STEELERS HAD A
TERRIBLE
OFFENSE OF LINE LAST YEAR.
THERE, THEY COULDN'T RUN THE
BALL WHATSOEVER. AND THEN
THEY RELEASE OR SOME
GUYS RETIRE OR YOU KNOW
THEY TURN OVER THEIR OFFENSIVE
LINE AND EVERYONE SAYS WELL
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT? WELL,
WHICH ONE IS
IT?
BUT WHICH ONE IS IT?
TELL ME WHICH ONE
WELL,
WELL, IT CAN BE BOTH.
IT COULD
KNOW WE HAD NOT LIKELY, HANG
ON, HANG ON. WE HAD A
CRAPPY OFFENSIVE LINE AND
OUR FOR BEST OFFENSIVE LINEMEN
ARE GONE. SO IT'S GOING TO
BE EVEN WORSE
WOULD BE, BUT IF THEY HAD A
TERRIBLE OFFENSIVE LINE, THEY
MUST NOT HAVE BEEN THAT GOOD
ANYMORE.
HOOP. BUT
WHO WANTS TO LIVE NEXT,
MAN, UP? NEXT? WHY UNDERSTAND?
WHY WOULD YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
I'M SAYING TO? YOU SAID HAVE
IT BOTH WAYS HERE? IF
THE
TO STEAL OUR HOME HAD A
TERRIBLE OFFENSIVE LINE LAST
YEAR AND IT WAS
LEGITIMATELY DRAFT AN
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN IN ROUND
ONE. SO DRAFT THE DRAFT, AN
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN TRADE UP.
YEAH. I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
THAT. BUT
THE BUT TURNING IT OVER,
I DON'T KNOW. I WANT TO SEE
IT. THERE'S ODDS. ARE THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO HAVE A BAD
OFFENSE OF WINE BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY HAD LAST YEAR, A BAD
OFFENSIVE LINE
SO THEY'RE AT LEAST TRYING TO
CHANGE IT.
TRY TO SHOW DRAFTED IN THE
FIRST ROUND.
ABSOLUTELY. THEY ALSO MIGHT
JUST BE LIKE,
LET'S JUST LET BIG BEN GET
KILLED. I DON'T KNOW.
LET'S I THINK THAT.
ROETHLISBERGER AND THE
STEELERS WILL
BY THE MIDDLE OF NOVEMBER
REGRET THAT HE CAME BACK FOR
ANOTHER YEAR. THEY GOT
THEMSELVES
ALL JUICED UP ON THIS IDEA
THAT
AND YOU KNOW, IT WAS IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE SEASON JUST
FAR ENOUGH REMOVED FROM IT. A
WE WERE 11 AND OH IF WE FIX
THIS FIX, THIS DO THIS WILL BE
FUN. MAYBE THEY FELL INTO
YOUR LINE OF REASONING.
WELL, YOU KNOW OUR OFFENSIVE
LINE WASN'T VERY GOOD. SO, WHO
CARES IF WE LOSE FOR OF THE
STARTERS FROM OUR OFFENSIVE
LINE?
NEXT MAN UP CAN'T BE MUCH
WORSE. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BRING
BIG BEND.
LET'S LET'S LOAD UP THE CANNON
ONE MORE TIME.
I JUST
THIS IS THE TOM BRADY
CONVERSATION
AT A HIGHER LEVEL. BEN
ROETHLISBERGER I THINK IS IN
THE PROCESS OF BREAKING
DOWN.
IT WAS THE ELBOW TWO YEARS
AGO. THE KNEES LAST
YEAR?
WERE CONSTANTLY AN ISSUE EVEN
THOUGH HE NEVER APPEARED ON
THE INJURY REPORT WITH A KNEE
PROBLEM. THERE'S A KNEE ISSUE,
IT MAY BE. THERE'S NOTHING TO
PUT ON THE INJURY REPORT
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
CARTILAGE AND IT'S ARTHRITIS
AND WHAT CAN YOU REALLY DO
FOR? IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE IN
THE TREATMENT ROOM FOR IT. YOU
JUST TRY TO DEAL WITH IT.
I JUST
JUST I THINK THAT IT'S NOT
GOING TO GO WELL FOR THE
STEELERS AND THIS DE CASTRO
THING, MAKES ME FEEL EVEN MORE
STRONGLY ABOUT IT. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE WHAT ELSE WE HAVE.
WHERE DO YOU UNDERSTAND MY
POINT. GO AHEAD.
YOU WON'T I GET YOUR POINT.
OKAY? BUT I DON'T SEE WHO
THEY'RE GOOD. THEY DRAFTED
AGAIN, ROUND TWO. I JUST DON'T
SEE WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE BETTER OFFENSIVE LINEMAN
THIS YEAR. OKAY
NOW, YEAH, LET ME LET ME
ADD THIS POINT THOUGH,
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU
AND I HAVE DISCUSSED THIS.
THERE WAS AN EXCELLENT ARTICLE
AT SOME POINT BY AT BRUSCHETTA
OF THE ATHLETIC TALKING
JEROME, BETTIS ABOUT
DIDN'T HAVE THE COMMITMENT TO
THE RUN AND IT'S A
MENTALITY THAT IS INSTILLED IN
TRAINING CAMP. SO I THINK MIKE
TOMLIN
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE NOT GOING
BACK TO ST. VINCENT COLLEGE
IN LATROBE
ANNOUNCED THAT YESTERDAY. BUT
DURING TRAINING CAMP, THEY'RE
GOING TO SPLIT IT BETWEEN
THEIR FACILITY AND HEINZ
FIELD
TOMLIN AND THE OFFENSIVE
COORDINATOR AND THE OFFENSIVE
LINE COACH. I THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO DO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'VE GOT FIVE GUYS WHO ARE
READY TO GO OUT THERE AND
AND AND BE AS AGGRESSIVE
AND IS DEDICATED
AND
AS DRIVEN AS POSSIBLE TO
OPENING HOLES FOR NAGI HARRIS
WILL SEE IF IT WORKS.
BUT,
YOU KNOW, AND I WOULD BE
SURPRISED TO MAKE A MOVE OR
TWO. WE'LL SEE WHO'S AVAILABLE
THAT THEY COULD BRING IN ON
THE OFFENSIVE LINE, BUT, AND
THEY SIGNED TREY TURNER
YESTERDAY, BY THE WAY, AFTER
CUTTING DAVID DE CASTRO. I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE, BUT IT JUST SHOWS
THAT THEY KNOW THEY NEED TO DO
SOMETHING
BROMANTE JONES. HEY, BIG CAT,
HOW MANY WINS DOES FAMOUS
JAMIS? EAT THIS YEAR? WE
TALKED EARLIER ABOUT HIM,
BEING AN OFF THE RADAR
MVP CANDIDATE. WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE SAINTS DO WITH
JAMIS UNDER CENTER IF HE'S THE
STARTER
RIDICULOUS.
IT'S NOT MY TASTE IN HILL
PROJECT AND SEAN
PAYTON'S TAYSOM HILL PROJECT.
HE'S GOT A SLIGHTLY MORE
IMPORTANT VOTE THAN I DO.
I'D HAVE TO LOOK AT THEIR
SCHEDULE, BUT I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO THROW IT OUT THERE.
I'M GOING TO THINK THAT THE
SAINTS ARE GOING TO GO.
THEY'RE GOING TO WIN 11
GAMES.
HOW MANY LETTING IT,
THEN THE
OVER/UNDERS NINE-AND-A-HALF?
MATT CASEY WAS TELLING ME. THE
OVER-AND-UNDER IS NOT AND A
HALF, SO I DIDN'T HEAR YOU SAY
11. SO 11 AND 6. STILL GOT
TO GET USED TO THAT,
NOT EASY TO DO.
I ACTUALLY THINK THEY CAN WIN
MORE THAN THAT, BECAUSE
THEIR DEFENSE IS STILL VERY
GOOD. THEY'VE GOT ALVIN
KAMARA. MICHAEL THOMAS IS
GOING TO BE HEALTHY AGAIN THIS
YEAR
AND AND SEAN PAYTON
IS THE MASTER OF
DRAWING UP ALL THE WAY UP
UNTIL KICKOFF
NEW
UNTIL KICKOFF NEW IDEAS. NEW
LOOKS NEW PLACE. AND YOU KNOW
BIG CAT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS.
ONE OF THE
FACTORS THAT I THINK WILL
DECIDE WHO STAYS AS
QUARTERBACK
WHICH OF THE GUYS BETWEEN
TAYSOM HILL AND JAMEIS WINSTON
IS THE MOST ADEPT
AT AT PROCESSING.
A NEW STACK OF PLAYS
THAT SEAN PAYTON IS WRITTEN UP
ON THE BACK OF THE NAPKIN FROM
BREAKFAST AS HE HAS YET
ANOTHER
BRAINSTORM BECAUSE HE NEVER
STOPS THINKING ABOUT NEW PLAYS
AND THEY INSTALL NEW PLAYS
ALL THE TIME
A WALKTHROUGH ON SUNDAY
MORNING
MORNING OF A GAME.
THEY'LL PUT IN NEW PLAYS WHICH
OF THE TWO GUYS CAN
PROCESS IT AND EXECUTE
IT
WITH LIMITED ADVANCE
PREPARATION, OR NOTICE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BIG
FACTOR IN WHO KEEPS THAT JOB
AS THE SEASON UNFOLDS.
YEAH. AGREED
II. LOOKING AT THAT SCHEDULE
JUST GLANCING AT I THINK THAT
THEY HAVE 11 WINS
THEIR THAT ROSTERS GOOD TO GO.
LIKE IT IS
IT. I'VE I WAS A LITTLE BIG
TIME BELIEVER THAT
DREW BREES WAS HOLDING THEM
BACK THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
AND THAT WAS A SUPER BOWL
WORTHY. ROSTER THAT HAD,
OH GLENN.
EARRING HOLE AT THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION WHEN THE
PLAYOFF GAMES GET HERE,
EVERYTHING GETS TIGHTER. YOU
CAN'T THROW DEEP, YOU CAN'T
STRETCH THE FIELD,
JAMEIS WINSTON CAN DO ALL
THAT. SO
I THINK, I THINK THE SAME
CIRCUIT HAVE A GOOD
YEAR.
AT GRIFF JANSEN'S. HOW MANY
WINS DO THE LIONS GET
BASED ON THE PURE
GRIT OF
DAN CAMPBELL?
THAT'S A GREAT QUALITY ODDS,
TO 1 TO WIN THE DIVISION.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION. I
THINK THEY GET AT LEAST TWO.
JUST ON GRIT
HONESTLY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY WIN THE
WINDS THEY HAVE
OVER ALL BUT TWO OF
THEIR THEY BEATEN, THERE'S THE
17 GAMES. GIVE ME THE WINDS,
WHERE THE WINDS ALL RIGHT?
WEEK ONE
MAN. WELL,
ALRIGHT, SO THEY'RE GOING TO
BEAT THE PACKERS.
NO PROBLEM GREEN BAY. THEY'RE
GOING TO WIN AT GRANT. COME
ON. COME ON, GO BEAT THE
BANGLES.
EAGLES WILL BE.
YEAH, I
IT MIGHT HAVE THREE WINS IN
HERE THE BRONCOS. MAYBE THE
CARD LIKE THAT ONE.
THAT STRETCHED STRETCHED AT
THE END OF THE SEASON SIX
GAMES,
YOU'LL GET ONE OUT OF THAT,
AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE.
YEAH,
FOUR
WINS 5 WITH 5 WINS. I'M GOING
TO THROW IT OUT THERE
BUYING FIVE AND TWELVE, FIVE
AND TWELVE. I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND
HERE'S THE REALITY.
WHAT THE LIONS ARE DOING
WITH KIND OF T
OLD-SCHOOL, CHRIS SPIELMAN
DAN CAMPBELL,
KNEECAP,
BITER VIBE.
IT'S SO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
OTHER TEAMS.
CURRENTLY DO THAT. IF YOU HAVE
GUYS WHO BUY IN,
IF YOU HAVE GUYS WHO WILL GO
OUT THERE AND BE KIND OF ROUGH
AND TUMBLE WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE RULES, THAT
DOES GIVE YOU AN EDGE BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT TEAMS
AREN'T DOING NOW. SO IT'S
GOING TO SURPRISE, HE'S GONNA
FRUSTRATE TEAMS, YOU KNOW,
THOSE TEAMS THAT ARE A LITTLE
EXTRA PHYSICAL THAT
PLAY THROUGH THE WHISTLE THAT
WILL DO THINGS, THAT OTHER
TEAMS WON'T DO THAT.
MAY BE PUT THROUGH TO GREATER
PHYSICAL RISK, EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE LEGAL, I'M NOT
ADVOCATING ANYTHING BEYOND
WHAT THE LAW AND THE
RULES
ALLOW.
OW, BUT IF YOU HAVE
A TEAM THAT PUSHES IT TO THE
LIMIT AT TEAM CAN BE, CAN BE A
PAIN IN THE ASS AND YOU DON'T
WANT TO DEAL WITH THEM AND I
FEEL LIKE THAT'S WHAT THE
LIONS ARE GOING TO BE.
I AGREE.
IT'S
THERE IS A CERTAIN
WINDOW HERE THAT DAN CAMPBELL
WILL HAVE GUYS PLAYING REALLY,
REALLY HARD FOR AND IF
HE CAN GET A COUPLE OF WINS
THAT, THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
GET
AND GUYS BELIEVING THAT CAN
BECOME SOMETHING THAT'S KIND
OF THE PATH HERE FOR
HIM.
AND HE'S GOT JARED, GOFF IS
HIS QUARTERBACK. SO I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S AND THAT'S WORTH
FIVE WINS IN AND OF ITSELF,
I DON'T LIKE YOUR AND
SEVEN YOU.
OKAY, YOU TAKE YOU WOULD TAKE
TAYSOM HILL OVER JARED GOFF
WHICH IS CRAZY. YES, I WOULD
THE GUY WHO PLAYS LIKE
A GADGET PLAYS A GAME IS YOUR
FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK.
AZ SKULL TO, CAN WE GET
SIMS VERSUS BIG CAT
AT ROUGH AND ROWDY SIMS
LOSSES, AND HE DOES THE SHOW
FIVE
DAYS. WE, I WOULDN'T MESS WITH
SIMS. I
WOULDN'T MESS WITH YOU.
ME EITHER, BUT I WOULDN'T MESS
WITH
SIMS II. DON'T HAVE TO REACH
HIS ALWAYS, THE BIG ADVANTAGE.
LISTEN, I
PLAYED A GAME, A WIFFLE BALL
ON WEDNESDAY AND
I AM STILL. SO SORE FROM IT.
MY DAYS ARE FAR, FAR AWAY.
FIND THAT
TWEET SOMEONE FIND THAT TREE
BECAUSE I, WE TALKED BY
BEN. I AM SO SORE.
I AM
JUST DEAD. I AM
WAY OVER THE HILL. THERE'S
IT'S OVER FOR ME, SO
THERE'S NOTHING THAT COULD GET
ME TO FIGHT IN ROUGH AND ROWDY
AND I LIKE SIMS EVEN THOUGH.
HE KEEPS OFFERING ME HIS JOB.
I DO GENUINELY LIKE SINS.
I
SAW SOME PHOTOS FROM WHATEVER
IT WAS, YOU GUYS WERE DOING.
WEDNESDAY.
AND
WE RELAX RELAX.
IT WAS, IT WAS DISTURBING.
THERE'S NOT MUCH AVOCADO ICE
CREAM BEING SERVED AT WHATEVER
YOU GUYS WERE DOING. I'LL JUST
SAY THAT.
RELAX, YOU'RE NOT,
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T LOOK SO
GREAT EITHER.
OKAY?
OKAY? I DON'T RUN AROUND MY
SHIRT OFF AND I'VE BEEN
PHOTOGRAPHED AND PUT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
I MYERS, I ADMIRE THE
WILLINGNESS
NEWSFLASH, MIKE, YOU KNOW
WHAT, HERE? TAKE THIS NEW.
TAKE, THIS BREAKING NEWS IN
HOPE,
HOPE THAT NO OTHER NFL
INSIDER STEALS IT FROM YOU.
I'M FAT. OKAY? THERE'S THE
BREAKING NEWS.
AS YOU GET CLOSER TO 40, THERE
ARE HEALTH REASONS IT PLAY.
I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE YOU
YOU KNOW, YOU GOT YOU GOT
APPRECIATE, YOU GOT TO BE
AROUND FOR THEM, ALL RIGHT,
I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
TOMORROW MORNING AND TOMORROW
MORNING YOU WILL INSPIRE
MILLIONS TO GO OUT AND BUY
DONUTS AS WE AWAIT ONCE A WEEK
MORNING
DO NOT WAIT, I'M
WAIT. I'M TELLING YOU, I, IT
IS INSPIRED ME TO BUY ANY
DOUGHNUTS BECAUSE THOSE THINGS
THAT YOU BUY,
WHEREVER YOU GET,
THEY LOOK DAMN GOOD. THE NEXT
TIME IN NEW YORK. I GOT TO GO
TO THAT BAKERY. OKAY.
YES
AT
LOW T
CONTESSA. WHY DON'T BIG CAT IN
FLORIO? GET MATCHING
TATS?
LIKE CHRIS SIMMS AND
SHANAHAN THEY ARE WAY CLOSER
AND
JUST
THREW IT DOESN'T KNOW. THE
STORY
COUGHS. SHANAHAN AND CHRIS
SIMS WERE TEAMMATES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS.
THEY HAVE EACH OTHER'S
INITIALS TATTOOED ON THEIR
LEGS. APPARENTLY, THEY AREN'T
THE ONLY ONES THERE WERE
MULTIPLE TEAMMATES. WHO DID
THE? SO THERE'S THIS LIST OF
LETTERS LIKE SOME WEIRD
DAVINCI CODE.
OH, DON CHRIS SIMMS LEG OF
LETTERS. SO
IF I'M GONNA GET A TATTOO, I'M
NOT GETTING LETTERS. I'M
GETTING SOMETHING MORE
INTERESTING THAN
LETTERS OR INITIALS I'M GOING
ALL IN.
DO YOU THINK CHRIS
LOOKS AT HIS
TAT NOW? AND HE JUST SEES, MAC
SEES, MAC JONES.
OR
TRAIL ANTS. ONE OF THE YEAH
ORIGIN
OR JUST SAYS OR JUST SAYS
SAYS, KYLE LIED TO ME.
YOU SHOULD GET A
CHANCE ROBIN LIKE HARRY
POTTER'S IT THROBS LIKE HARRY
POTTER'S SCAR ON HIS FOREHEAD.
HE SEES THE KS, AND IT'S JUST
LIKE, IT'S LIKE
INFECTED NOW 20 YEARS AFTER
HE DID THE ACTUAL TEST I'VE
EVER READ THAT
LIKE
I DON'T HAVE A TATTOO.
BUT I TIME AS I GET OLDER,
I HAVE THIS WEIRD URGE TO GO
GET ME TO KNOW WHAT IT WOULD
BE, BUT I WANT TO GET
ONE
ME TOO.
IVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
EXTENSIVELY. I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU CAN JUST BE
36 YEARS OLD AND BECOME TATTOO
GUY. BUT I WANT TO BE, I DON'T
KNOW HOW I DO IT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO DO IT. YOU CAN'T
JUST LIKE START GETTING A TON
RIGHT AWAY IF THE EASE YOUR
WAY INTO IT. HOW DO YOU DO
IT? WHERE IT'S NOT LIKE SUPER.
YOU KNOW, IN YOUR FACE
I ALSO I THINK
WE
MOST AGREE.
I'M PROBABLY NEVER GOING TO
HAVE A REAL JOB MY ENTIRE LIFE
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
HOPEFULLY, KNOCK ON WOOD. SO I
CAN GET A TATTOO MAYBE
A NECK TATTOO,
MAYBE A FACE TATTOO AND
PROBABLY STILL DO MY JOB.
YEAH. I
LOOK,
I'VE GOT 20 YEARS ON YOU. AND
I THINK ABOUT IT. SO I DON'T
THINK IT'S UNREASONABLE TO
THINK ABOUT IT, NOT THAT I
WOULD GET A NECK
TO HER FACE TATTOO,
AND I KNOW YOU'RE NOT SERIOUS
ABOUT IT, BUT HEY, IF YOU
CHOOSE TO DO IT, GO FOR IT.
I THINK WE JUST TALKED.
OURSELVES INTO DOING THIS
GETTING MATCHING TATS.
LET'S DO
IT. WE GOT TO LET'S JUST
DO IT. LET'S BE WILD AND
CRAZY
MY LAST DAY BEFORE VACATION
LAST DAY OF SCHOOL.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT QUESTION.
WHICH ONE? HERE WE GO.
AT A ROADS, 27. BIG
CAT FIRST TIME LONG TIME WHEN
YOU BUY YOUR DONUTS ON
SATURDAY MORNINGS. DO YOU PLAN
IT OUT AHEAD OF TIME?
YOU'RE JUST CAUGHT UP IN THE
MOMENT AND IMPROVISE.
IMPROVISED KNOW, SO THE PLACE
I GO TO IN
BROOKLYN
IT'S GOT IT HAS A
LIMITED SELECTION. SO EVERYONE
ALWAYS
CRITICIZES LIKE OH HOW DID YOU
NOT GET JELLY?
HOW'D YOU, THEY DON'T, THEY
MAKE WHATEVER THEY MAKE. IT'S
A PLACE WHERE IT
OPENS
AT 9 A.M.
AND THEY JUST SELL DONUTS
UNTIL IT'S CALLED UNTIL THEY
RUN OUT AND THAT'S HOW YOU
KNOW, A PLACE IS GREAT.
LIKE IT'S USUALLY OUT AT
NOON,
BUT I DO NOT, I
SORT OF
INFORMAL IMPROVISE BUT THERE'S
NOT A LOT TO WORK WITH.
THEY'RE THE BEST THING THAT
I'VE EVER HAD IN MY LIFE.
I ENJOY MY SATURDAY MORNING.
I GO WITH MY SON, WE HAVE A
LITTLE MOMENT,
IT'S GREAT. IT'S A LITTLE
TRADITION.
SO EVERYONE WHO HATES ON IT.
TAKE A HIKE. OKAY, I DON'T
WANT. I DON'T WANT ANY
NEGATIVE VIBES ON SATURDAY
MORNINGS.
YOU HAD ONE RECENTLY.
THAT IT LOOKED LIKE IT
HAD AND
CATHOLIC MY WHOLE LIFE. I WAS
AN ALTAR. BOY,
THE PRIEST ALWAYS HAD THE BIG
GIANT COMMUNION WAFER. IT
LOOKED LIKE HALF OF THE BIG
GIANT COMMUNION WAFER ON
TOP OF THE ICING. YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT?
YES, YES. I THINK THAT WAS A
COOKIES AND CREAM ONE, SO
YEAH.
THEY'RE, I MEAN, THEY'RE,
THEY'RE INCREDIBLE AND I
AGAIN, I LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
IT'S A NICE LITTLE THING THAT
I DO WITH MY SON.
IT'S JUST FUN TO BE ABLE TO
WAKE UP AND BE LIKE
OKAY, LET'S GET IN THE CAR.
GRAB SOME COFFEE
GRABS. DOUGHNUTS.
BRING IT BACK FOR THE FAMILY.
GUESS WHAT? I LIKE
IT.
NEWS FLASH, YOU GOT YOUR
TWO-YEAR-OLD SON. HEPPED UP ON
CAFFEINE.
IT'S A LITTLE EARLY THAT HE
HAS THE
CALL. HE ACTUALLY MAKES THE
COFFEE FOR ME.
LET'S
SAY I'VE NOTICED THAT YOU HAVE
BECOME IN RECENT WEEKS. QUITE
THE COFFEE
AFICIONADO AS WELL. THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY LONGER THAN WEEKS.
I JUST LOVE JUST THE MEMES
BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE LIKE,
YOU'RE SO LAME.
YOU'RE SO OVER THE HILL. IT'S
LIKE, YEAH, I KNOW, I MEAN, I
LITERALLY GOOGLE
LAME COFFEE MEMES AND THEN
POST IT ON T